hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2019 I'm Mike McCarty
I'll be here for the rest of the day
along with Lucy James hello and we are
pleased to be joined by Rod Fergusson
studio head over at the coalition rod
you just got to show off much more of
Gears of War 5 a couple days ago at the
Microsoft conference what's it like to
have more of it out there
it feels great you know after we're not
being able to talk for an entire year it
feels good to be able to talk about
everything that we're doing right now
and the plan to how we're gonna talk
going forward you know people are always
wanting more information and we're like
yeah like this is our time to talk about
escape our new co-op mode but July it's
gonna be about versus and being have the
tech test Kenny people playing and
August is all about horde september's
back to campaign so not only what we're
talking about but their ability to like
know when the next things coming and how
was a fan reaction to the xbox showcase
that's great has been really great you
know at finding a new mode and having an
aggressive way to play is really
important for us and just it turns it
all on its head like if you play board
it's a little bit more of a defensive
way to play you need five players it
takes a couple hours whereas Escape is
really a three player it's very
aggressive moving forward and it takes
about 20 and 30 minutes to be to hive so
it's really more about taking sort of
what you know about gears and sort of
flipping it on its head yeah it's funny
because throughout its history gears has
had like for most of its history gears
said that those three pillars like
campaign horde mode and PvP but now
would you say escape mode is like a
fourth pillar to the to the game work
because it's more than just like just a
new PvP mode it's its own thing
yeah it's well that's part of like it's
inside the PvE camp that idea that co-op
but you know whenever you think about
Gears 5 it's really about five ways to
play as we have our campaign we have
escape horde which is the 2d PvE mode we
have vs but we also have a map builder
now so it's starting offs gonna be
supporting escape so then not only are
you busting hives and going in and
playing that you're able to build hives
as well and once you prove that you can
beat it then you can put it out there
and challenge your friends and and other
players could you tell us about escape
from like a top-down level cuz we saw we
saw a lot of it at during Microsoft a
little bit of it during Microsoft and
few characters but uh right how will how
will that mode function once we get our
hands on the game yeah it's it's the
whole premise of it basically is that
you have this sort of Suicide Squad of
these three characters we're willing to
get snatched and potted and take
to the heart of the hive and so what
they do is they go into it and they they
basically cut themselves out of the pod
they plant this venom bomb and then they
run for it and so basically you have
this poison cloud chasing you like the a
rolling Boulder behind Indiana Jones so
you have this poison cloud chasing you
and you have all these monsters blocking
your way out so it's basically like that
you can't stop and slow down
you only have a pistol and a knife so
everything you need to find it has to be
found in the hive so every kill now is a
new rifle and you got to find a new room
to find ammo and grenades that kind of
stuff so you have to both learn the map
and then figure out tactics and ways to
get through all you know saving
ammunition and getting out in time and
then what's really cool that it is it's
really based around this idea of
demonstrating mastery as well as
speedruns so it has eight different
levels of difficulty where we can add
them different modifier over time and
like you can add it every time you beat
one you can add another modifier add
another modifier I don't know the mile
all the way up to master so we start a
beginner all the way the master and once
you get to master then you starting to
put times on a leaderboard for speed so
I kind of shorten it down you got to get
good and then you gotta get fast and
then then win on the leaderboards based
on how fast you are
then we'll give cosmetic awards to
people who've earned them for showing us
are the best at that particular hive
what do you think there are a few games
that have a synonymous with a mode as
Gears is with horde right when it comes
to creating a new game-mode what is
going through your head when it comes to
approaching it and attaching it to Gears
yeah I mean really it's about finding
sort of a space for it to exist in you
know we've tried different things with
beast mode and overrun and all these
different types of modes so you're
trying to find something that's just not
sort of a an add-on or something just
slightly different we want it to be
something that feels very uniquely
different and a completely different
playstyle
like I said we saw a great opportunity
with this shorter duration more
aggressive and now it's essentially a
class-based system because one of the
big changes for Gears 5 is these
characters have ultimate abilities so
it's not just about before it was about
your weapons and so if I want to be an
engineer I could be Dell or I could be
Jade here I can be Cade I didn't matter
the class was independent from the
character and that's not true anymore so
with the three characters you see like
that's Keegan he's a support class so
he's got a rapport and resupply station
he can put down and give ammo to his
teammate
Mack as a tank he has a barrier shield
that he can put up to protect others
when he's rescuing people and then
Lonnie's our Scouts she's this one
really aggressive she has an electro
blade that she'll use and be able to
take out a bunch of people and stun them
and chain lightning though what was the
thought process behind going from that
change from having these you know iconic
character skins that just like give you
the choice of which class to use as
opposed to Gears 5 which it's almost
like it's kind of inspired by hero
shooters where it's this noticeable
recognizable person who you kind of have
these associated abilities women who
always have be that ability always be
this class was that what was the
decision behind that kind of change yeah
we just wanted the characters that have
a little bit more everything meaning and
depth and I mean the fact that you could
be any class with any character just
meant it didn't you know if you like
Kate you could be Kate on everything and
we wanted you don't have to feel like oh
actually I want to play a different
style so I'll plays a different
character you get to experience the
other characters we had a little bit of
that in judgment with overrun you know
that Baird was the engineer and coal
would cost an ammo crisis Society of
going back to that and having these
classes associated with the character
then you can level up your character you
like Oh
Keegan's level 10 I'm gonna go and level
up Kate now or I'm gonna go level up you
know Mac or Lonnie and those sorts of
things so it kind of creates a different
sort of perspective in the play we
talked a little bit about the Terminator
teased sure how did that come about uh
yeah I was just one of the things that
you know we've always been fans of the
Terminator franchise and we're here
coming back with James Cameron and and
Linda Hamilton and we were just really
excited about when we look at Sarah
Connor as a character it really
resonated with us in terms of how we've
been telling Kate's story you know Kate
went from this sort of outsider civilian
into this warrior not assigned to help
save humanity and it's kind of a same
story for Sarah Connor and so this idea
of being able to bring these two
franchises together in a really cool way
is exciting to us so yeah so anybody who
pre-orders or if anybody who plays in
the first week if you have like game
Pass for example you'll get the
character pack which will be the t800
Sarah Connor plus a bunch of cosmetics
around a dark fate movie and what's
really really exciting and I'm really
excited about is that Linda is actually
going to do the voice for Sarah Connor
so yeah so in a couple of weeks were to
go in the booth with her and start
recording so it's gonna be exciting were
you aware of the fact that terminate is
also going to be in Ghost Recon
something that was new it was
interesting they're like I think
obviously a dark fate is a huge movie so
I think and I've seen a little bits and
pieces of it now and I'm really excited
for what its gonna how the movies
looking seems like dere's more fives
making a bunch of changes with how
characters function and you're obviously
adding the new mode are you gonna be
changing at all how you release that
content cuz gears war has always been
you know here's where we'll come out and
horde mode we'll have X number of maps
but like you're releasing them
episodically is anything in that regard
gonna change with five that you know if
I mean if I know of ya know it's not a
question about how to phrase it - you
can say yeah hope you would know yeah I
mean basically we're looking at you know
gears for was sort of our first attempt
at a sort of service is too strong of a
word a games of the service but that
idea of like really lengthening the
sustain was really important to us and
so finding this way of delivering
content it's one of the things right now
like gears for if you go to download it
it's like a hundred gig download and
people are like what's a hack like 100
gig is such a big game you're like
because we put it two maps every month
for two years tonight Kenna you know
there's a ton of yeah just we put it a
lot of content and so as we look to
Gears 5 we want to have a same sort of
like how do we deliver the right content
at the right time and especially when
you look at how we support map builder
as an example and how we support east
force because those are things that you
can sort of definitely deliver more
content outside of the box and so yeah
we're definitely looking at like how do
we bring in new characters and new
cosmetics and all those sort of things
first for these this is an eSport what
are your kind of performance indicators
that you're looking at in terms of how
gears as an eSport is performing yeah I
mean when we started back into eSports
like when we were back in the original
trilogy when I was at epic with one two
and three we really didn't pay that much
attention to professional gamers we were
sort of like they're the 1% of our
audience and they're gonna do what
they're gonna do so we're just gonna
focus on the mainstream and we sort of
let them do whatever they were doing and
so I was really happy when in 2014 when
I came into the coalition we really made
it a big part of our plan and so with
the Ultimate Edition we said okay we're
gonna we're gonna crawl we're just gonna
figure this out over to make a bunch of
mistakes but at least we'll learn I'm
really the Ultimate Edition as a remake
of Gears one didn't have any of the
tools didn't have a good spectator mode
didn't have all the things you really
need
for an esport so with gears 4 we feel
like ok when I'm gonna try to walk and
so now we get great content being
produced we're talking about the players
and we're really focused on what are the
different kinds of things we could do as
an eSport and now you know we've had
such big succes like two and a half
years after launch we still have the
biggest viewing we've ever had at one of
our events so the show is the value of
eSports and sort of keeping that
continuity through sustain and now we're
like holy I feel like we're on the cusp
of running now in our plan because we're
on eleague we're gonna be a national
television you know and we've got even
more tools and even more things that we
can change desk elation and you'll find
out lots about that in July but we're
just really embracing that and it's not
at the detriment of the rest like that
I've talked about on the stage this mode
called arcade and arcade is really a
mode that's really tailored to the mass
and so but we still also have to stay
focused on what our eSports program is
gonna be like there's this sense like I
think the Coalition is one of the more
interesting studios working today in a
similar sense that 343 was formed
specifically to create Halo games you
have a namesake of Gears war in your
name the coalition alright it's
fascinating to me obviously with
Ultimate Edition like you said it was a
remake of the first game for use even
set it on stage at Microsoft you kind of
said like we wanted to prove that we
could make a Gears game you know like
maybe there was a bit of a sense of
playing it safe just to show fans hey we
know what we're doing right would you
say 5 is the time or you just get to run
off and be weird and do some really cool
things existing formula yeah we're
pretty weird already so but yeah that
was that you know really it we only had
out of our entire team only three of us
have made a Gears game before when we
did Gears you know for an Ultimate
Edition so we really focused on ok let's
get it right before we start changing
anything and I was just really surprised
like we don't you know had this plan
about how to talk to people on like hey
please trust us we know we're and very
quickly like the first e3 they were like
okay we're good now what's what are you
doing new and I'm like oh crap
I was really set up to try to prove
ourselves a lot more than this so you
know I loved what we did was for I do
think you know we purposely States on
the path and so it's five we have an
opportunity to kind of you know like I
say push the envelope to going to go off
the path a little bit more and try new
and different things with the game both
in new modes but also what we're doing
with campaign
and just even what we're doing with the
gunplay like we've really enhanced the
gunplay that the reticle works
completely different the hard works
completely differently the guns feel
different and I feel I personally feel
like they're tighter so we've sort of
had to modernize it and make it more
contemporary in sort of the world of
shooters that are out to today and like
you'll see a lot as we talk about it
from now to September you'll see like oh
okay I was surprised but I changed I
mean let's talk more about the campaign
it didn't even show that much of it
right yeah but last year we got a good a
good look at what we can expect
what other things that you think of
gonna surprise fans from the campaign I
just think there's a lot to surprise
them with you know today at our Coliseum
panel we introduced our new cast member
heiko Lee who plays FAR's and we got to
show his cinematic of that with his
introduction and so having new cast
members is always exciting but you can
sort of see in though in that last
year's trailer like the kinds of things
were we're sort of talking to that you
know gears has traditionally been a
hallways shooter and you can see with
this gif and some of the gameplay things
we're showing that we're trying to kind
of open it up a little bit more and so I
think you'll be excited about sort of
the opportunities and the possibilities
that we have there I'm also curious like
tonally with the campaign like years
where for there was some talk about
going back to gears Semite horror roots
right with gears where five is it gonna
be a continuation of four are you gonna
try to go off in a different tonal
atmospheric sense yeah I mean we're
trying to kind of embrace the tone of
the story even more I think he's doing
Kate's journey and when we've had our
kid broken you know teaser at the
beginning of our segment which shows
that there's a lot of conflict within
her and so we want to have tell more of
that story and some of the things we're
actually doing purposely now to kind of
we feel like like when we first were
doing the first trilogy there was a big
pressure about no don't do visuals I
don't put anything on the hood so we did
a lot with sound and so every action the
character does makes a sound somebody
says something you're active reload you
say something you miss it you say
something you shoot you say something
most of what you probably can't say I'm
right and so we found that actually now
after you know 14 years that the Omaha
dialogue is built up built up built up
that you're hearing so much combat
chatter that it starts to dilute the
actual story dialogue so one of the
things we really did with
five as we went in and started scrubbing
a lot of that stuff out and trying to
minimize so the tone of the story stays
the same you don't have this like sad
moment in a cheer for your actor we load
back to the sad moment kind of thing so
he really been trying to stay focused on
consistency of tone throughout the story
for people who haven't been able to play
yet you mentioned the kind of
backtracking here do you mentioned you
do want to make it feel more modern yeah
how would you describe the difference
between how gears used to feel and how
years v feels yeah I mean if you look at
like all the way back to the OG days
with Halo 1 they kind of figured out how
to do dual stick console shooter right
and that notion of how a reticle works
and and having pretty much a steady gun
but Blum be the indication of accuracy
or inaccuracy and we've had that for a
long time and so for five we actually
went in and and can basically redesigned
how that works and so instead of relying
on Blum out of the weapon we actually
rely a lot more on recoil and so what
that means is though is that each weapon
has a different feel now and has a
personality of its own and it actually
creates a little bit of a skill gap
because you once you learn that enforcer
kind of pulls up into the left you can
actually start to counter it as you're
playing it so you can get better with an
enforcer as you learn it's recoil
pattern and you find that the you'll see
like the reticles are much more precise
they're not like a lot of big circles
they tend to be a little bit more
precise about where they're going and it
gives you a lot more feedback and that's
one of the things you see on the screen
is that basically we have oh you know
you hit so there's a white little axe
comes off it or you hit a weak spot or
red X comes off of it oh you hit a weak
spot with an after reload of gold X
comes off of it and then hold flashed
out when you kill something so there's a
lot more information coming to you
through the reticle which is really
exciting to kind of get people to learn
the weapon in terms of how it feels
obviously we still have like characters
that we know from Gears 4 and before
that but in terms of how it feels is
there ever a point where you worried
that you might it might not even feel
like a Gears game anymore are you pretty
almost always pretty confident that no
matter even if you make these - changes
it's always gonna feel like gears no
we're always looking at that that's one
of our big questions is a still a Gears
game is a you know how do we make I
don't how does this stay true to Gears
well still pushing it that's why we're
not trying to break it too much you know
I talk a lot about when you're doing
sequels you have to worry about the sort
of big managing the betrayal of
expectations right if i betray your
expectations too little you're like ask
the same game as last time I'd want to
play
if i betray them too much you're like
that's not even a huge game anymore and
so you have to find this middle ground
where you land on surprise and delight
like oh I wasn't expecting that no it's
really cool and so that's what we're
constantly talking about is like okay
how far can we push it how much can we
do to make it feel different and special
but not feel like we're breaking the
formula that makes the gears gaming here
yeah my cover is still really important
co-op is still really important
character-driven story is still really
important like the things that make us
who we are it's still there but we're
pushing it all the different places
where we can go you're looking at other
games of inspiration I mean I think
there's lots of stuff I think the hero
shooter reference I mean when we look at
him ovas and things like that is
something where you go like oh there's
things here that we can be popping into
around playing into those ability is the
same thing when you look at I can escape
but I actually have not only we have
health bar and numbers coming off in
this big part of that has to do with if
I'm gonna get abilities in cars allow me
to upgrade myself by earning them then I
want to see that damage change or if I'm
doing 100 and I get a 12% increase I
want to see 112 and so in the modes you
can have some modes use just health bar
or some know some use both some use
neither and so it's an option you can
turn on and off but it creates this
great feeling because if you see a
health bar and I'm on a boss you now
know I'm gonna go in like I can know
it's right down I'm gonna charge and try
they get much many more clutch moments
because you have a better sense of when
to rush in with the shotgun and try to
make that last kill
whereas before you're like I think it's
kind of hurt I've seen a lot of blood
come off of it but I'm not sure if I
should commit and so now you can
actually tell like oh now's the time to
go and it feels really really good
alright last question I'm sure it's
pretty loaded but you're head of the
coalition estudio those formed
specifically to make gears games you've
got your next big release and only a few
months from now in September what what
makes a Gears game a Gears game if you
had to answer that semi succinctly yeah
I mean we've been asking ourselves that
question as we go to different platforms
you know gears tactics on PC gears pop
on mobile and so we had to realize that
the things we used to say were part of
our brand Bible that we had to have you
know like brutality was something that
was like there has to be brutal and then
when we got the gears pop were like well
maybe it doesn't have to be brutal to be
a mobile game and but we did like one of
the big things about
mobile game as it has to have cover and
it has to have strong characters and so
those are the things we've actually been
looking at oh there's an umbrella around
co-op or shared experiences cover strong
characters but then as you get into each
execution whether it's console PC mobile
and even as we go beyond that now with
our comic book series is our novel and
even in the movie we talk about like
okay what are those things mean in each
of those forums and so it's exciting
awesome well Rod Fergusson thank you so
much for joining us and good luck with
everything leading up to the September
release of Gears of War 5 alright thank
you if you're watching from home we will
be right back after a short break with
our friends from Borderlands 3 thanks so
much for joining we'll see you then
[Music]
[Applause]